Tal Tochner, thank you for joining me
in 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm great.
I'm really excited to be here.
Thank you so much for having me.
Well, I'm really excited
that you are here.
So, where are you calling from right now?
I'm calling from our office in Tel Aviv.
Okay. The PICO offices.
The PICO offices, that's right.
Wonderful. Wonderful. Okay.
Well, I'm glad to see that things
are still happening there,
even though the situation is so dire.
But hopefully, by the time this airs,
it'll die down a bit
and things will get a little bit better.
First, I want to talk about
morning dance parties.
What is that all about?
Oh, my goodness.
So, I have an incredible morning routine
that includes writing and gratitude,
and meditations, and a bit of yoga.
But my favorite part is relax in the music
that wakes up all my neighbors super early
and just dancing that off the wall.
I love it. I love it. Okay.
I've been trying to get
into morning routine myself, but I,
and everybody's been telling me
about the meditation
and gratitude part.
I think that I'm going to start
by adopting this morning dance party.
And then move on to those
because that seems like
a really nice part of it.
Tal, I'm going to let you
talk a little bit about your journey.
Because I'm not going to be able
to do justice.
But just a small recap.
Currently, an investor within PICO,
you are also a Forbes 30 under 30,
founded several organizations,
WMN, part of them.
But you also did a lot of other work
in terms of female empowerment
and leadership globally,
not just in tech.
And I'd love to actually
get started with that in just a second.
And then weave the conversation
into how you invest within PICO,
and what do you bring to the table
for the both portfolio companies,
but also a part of your investment thesis.
So, Tal, take us away.
Talk to me a little bit
about your journey.
Where you're from,
and how you got to where you are?
Amazing.
So, I was born and raised in the US.
In Newark, New Jersey.
I moved to Israel when I was about 16.
And I've been here ever since.
Did spent some time in the army.
Went to Hebrew University.
And was, to be honest with you,
I've wanted always to be a diplomat.
And from that dream, somehow,
I became a venture capitalist.
A little bit different.
A little different, but much of the same.
What is the same between being a diplomat
and being a venture capitalist?
I'm really passionate about Israel
and telling Israel's phenomenal story.
So, as a venture capitalist,
I get the opportunity to tell
the economic phenomenal story
and not the side of a political one.
And I feel like that brings
a lot of great things together.
Okay. And so, growing up
to become a diplomat,
what does that entail?
Is that like model United Nations
and that sort of stuff?
How do you set yourself up
to become a diplomat
and then make that rapid transition
into venture capital?
So, I took to learn lot of
international and global
learning experiences and conferences.
Whether it was the model UN,
whether it was international diplomacy,
peace building, humanitarian aid.
I was traveling around the world
and taking part
in unique learning experiences
in order to acquire the soft skills
that will help me succeed.
And the learning experiences
that will helped me
become better professionally.
And when I started university,
I set out to study
Chinese and international relations
because I thought that would position me
in a very unique way
to go into foreign service.
Because not many people speak Chinese,
definitely not about [--].
And it's more relevant than ever.
More relevant than ever.
And that actually took me
to the business side,
and not the diplomatic side,
which is surprising.
And I'm extremely grateful
and happy about that.
So, what was your first dip
into the business side of things
out of the diplomacy side?
So, towards the end of my first year
of university,
I decided to intern for an incredible CEO,
Rebecca Zeffert at the Israel Asia Center.
Which is an incredible organization
that basically fosters collaborations
between Israel
and all countries around Asia.
Specifically around economic ties.
And that basically was my entry point
to the entire startup ecosystem
here in Israel.
I was hosting
high level senior delegations
of investors and entrepreneurs
and government officials
and connecting them
to the localized system here.
Were you able to use any of the Chinese
you learned in university,
or was that not even a part of it?
My Chinese is not as good
as I hoped it would be.
Very very nice.
Okay. Now talk to me a little bit
about this thing that you founded,
which you're empowering female leaders,
not necessarily in tech,
but in all sectors.
And you're doing it in a pretty cool way.
So, tell me a little bit about
what that program was about
and then we'll transition
to some of the investments.
About five years ago,
I co-founded an organization
called the Women's Parliament,
that really fosters female leadership
across the board, all over Israel.
And for me personally,
it was extremely important to invest
in mid to senior leadership.
But also showcase the various,
Israel's extremely unique, right?
We have a lot of
different sectors and societies.
And I wanted to make sure
that we have everyone there
as a whole.
So, we have women that
from the public sector,
from the private sector,
from non-profits,
from all across Israel,
from south to north.
We have Haredi women,
we have Arab women,
we have Olean, new immigrants.
And this program really sets out
to help them acquire skill sets
that they're going to need in order
to become the future leaders of Israel.
Now, what does that
actually mean tangibly?
So then, you join this program,
you identify these women,
what do you actually do with them
to make that leap?
So, we have meetings every so often
with either thought leaders
or entrepreneurs or government leaders
that tell their personal stories,
but also give them help.
Also provide a practical skill
that these females can use
within their own organizations.
And through that,
we also foster relationships
and mentorship,
and friendships amongst the women
that to really help them increase
their network in order to succeed.
So, when I looked at my own network,
I said,
"Okay. I'm very much in high tech,
in a startup ecosystem."
I don't know anything else around me.
Definitely not at the time, right?
And if I want to succeed
in a really meaningful way,
I need to establish
a much broader network.
And that's how this came to be.
And that's what was so important for us.
To bring in women
that really depict all of Israel's society
from all different sectors.
And there have been a lot of
really great outcomes and friendships
and collaborations that have come
out of this incredible form.
And so, are there any common threads
that you've noticed among the members
in this program where
there are specific things
that collectively they need
or collectively are looking for
as they join this program
and are making the leap?
Yes. I think women as a whole
have a lot of challenges
as they step up from mid-level,
to senior level to executives.
And there's a lot that always happens
around negotiation skills
a lot about internal politics,
a lot about management, right?
When you move from mid-level
to senior level,
and how do you manage a team,
and how do you manage
the time effectively.
A lot about productivity,
a lot about facilitation of relationships
and strategic partnerships.
Those are things that are common threads
that across the industries
you deal with on a day to day level.
And was it helpful
that this is a community
that is strictly for women
in terms of their empowerment?
Because all of these skills
are hugely relevant
to both genders, right?
But I'm trying to assess whether
the fact that it's a community
that it's by women for women,
gives them a little bit more flexibility
and more confidence
to go and utilize them.
100%. I think that it provides
a really strong foundation
where you're not afraid
to raise your hands and ask the question.
Where you don't feel
like you're constantly being judged.
Where you can really come and be yourself,
and be your authentic self.
And really create
those meaningful relationships that will
really help you take yourself
to the next level.
Wonderful.
Okay, Tal, so you forwent
your passion for diplomacy
to go into investing.
Today you're at PICO.
You've had a couple of other gigs
with investing before.
Talk to me a little bit about investing.
What is investing for you?
And what do you do specifically at PICO
that you're so excited about?
So, at PICO Partners,
I have an incredible opportunity
to really work with founders.
We're really early stage fund.
So, where normally the first
institutional money in the company.
So, sometimes we invest really
at the idea phase.
So, I get to work with entrepreneurs
from in idea and presentation
and help them build companies.
And that's something
that's so exciting for me.
Everything from the ideation,
to the productization
to the go to market strategy,
to hiring and business development
and setting up shop in a global country.
It's an incredible, it's something
that gets me really excited
to wake up every day to do.
So, walk me through your day to day.
You arrive in the morning,
or you're in the beginning of the week
at PICO Partners,
and what is the day in the life
of Tal Tochner look like?
Every day is different.
There is no common thread.
I spend a lot of time
meeting with entrepreneurs
and learning about new industries
and understanding whether,
hearing a lot of pitches
and trying to think whether
these are valuable businesses
and scalable businesses
that fit our investment thesis.
And a big part of my work also
goes to actually working
with the entrepreneurs
that I invested in
on their daily challenges.
Making sure that,
we're going through really rough times
all around the world,
corona, covid-19 has really impacted
a lot of businesses
and a lot of markets globally.
And I want to be my entrepreneur's
biggest cheerleader.
And I want to make sure
that they have what it takes.
And I can be helpful for them
to make it through successfully.
And sometimes that entails
working with them on hiring
and refining their value proposition
or their go to market strategy,
doing some market research.
And I do a lot of work
with the entrepreneurs
in all of those things.
So, how does that actually
the process start?
Because the way that I'm looking at this,
especially in the very very early stage,
so, let's say the ideation phase,
the entrepreneur has become
really experts in this domain.
They become truly passionate about this.
What is your role
as the institutional fund
that comes in and supports them
into helping them encapsulate
this ideation into a product, hire,
follow on to their future investments?
How do you actually go
and follow these entrepreneurs?
Is it, do you have a set things
that you expect them to do,
or you expect yourself to do?
Or is it more dynamic for entrepreneur?
It's very dynamic for entrepreneur.
I think different entrepreneurs
value many different things.
But ultimately,
I will never know better sector,
or a specific technology
better than the entrepreneur that's there
and working day to day.
But I do have an incredible benchmark,
having seen a lot of different companies,
a lot of different scenarios.
Researching a lot of different markets
that I can come from
with an outside view and be,
Hey, what do you think about that?
Hey, this worked well with this company.
Why don't you think of utilizing this
for you in this case as well?
And that's I think,
where venture capitalists
can be real value added
and helpful to the entrepreneurs.
Okay. And is there a specific market
that you're particularly excited about?
Or, is that very agnostic?
Oh, wow.
So, I'm very generalist
and I'm very agnostic.
But I'm extremely passionate
about the future of work.
Digital health space
is something I'm looking
a lot into right now.
Deep tech I'm really excited about.
Those are things
that I'm really deep diving on.
But I look at a lot of different sectors.
So, give me a couple of insights
into this idea of digital health,
the future of the workplace.
Because obviously that's something that's
hugely relevant to myself,
to anybody that's listening on the show,
to any entrepreneur
that is starting out their journey.
What are some of the trends
that you've been seeing
over the past few months?
And if I ask you, Tal, what do you think
are the key cornerstones,
or key milestones as we move along
in this new reality?
When I look at the future of work,
the way we're working is likely
to fundamentally change.
We're now getting used
to working remotely.
What does that mean?
How do you manage teams effectively?
How do you secure the network?
Think about all these
heavy enterprises that are on print,
how do you move employees
effectively work from home.
Connectivity. We spoke about communication
between teams, building culture,
all of that.
There's so much opportunity and things
that are going to have to change
in our day to day.
Right. No no. Go ahead.
When I think about digital health,
is global pandemic really pause
a lot of opportunities for companies
to really disrupt remote care.
We see telemedicine right now booming.
How do you,
and I think right now
consumers are used to getting
a lot of their services remotely.
And I think that's something
that's going to be very hard
to go back to the old days.
So, I think right now,
when I look at hospitals
and I look at clinics,
and I look at private practices
and I look at the payers
and they're going to have to do
a lot of work to transition.
And in order to stay relevant
and keep up with the trend
and what consumers are expecting to have.
So, what's important for you
when you meet an entrepreneur
and you're considering joining them
on the journey?
What sort of like your thesis into,
these are things that I'm excited about
and that I trust,
these are things
that I'm a little bit more worried about?
And obviously,
this is something that would go a long way
for any young entrepreneur watching us.
So, as an early stage investor,
the thing I look at
and spend the most time on
is the team.
Why did they choose to go after this,
this specific industry or problem?
Why are they best positioned to solve it?
What are they most passionate about?
What's the purpose behind
what they're doing?
And I think you would know, right?
Founding a startup
and being an entrepreneur,
is something that's extremely difficult.
The cycles of the success
are never linear.
There are always loops.
And you need to have a lot of resilience
and a lot of great endurance
in order to succeed.
And you need to be very mission driven.
And so, that's something
that I spend a lot of time on.
And again, I personally am excited about
things that are going to change
the way we live,
the way we consume things,
the way we operate,
that will impact our lives.
And also, on the other hand,
operational efficiency,
innovative business models.
Fixing broken business processes
in old industries,
which is what's exciting for me
in digital health, for instance.
So, I look on the team
and the market opportunity primarily.
So, one of the things
that I'm always very excited about
and we're very interested in is
how different institutions
come into a startup
and now have to play
a similar role, different role,
depending on the round that they join.
How do you, as an investor,
come in and see this relationship
also with other investors
who come into the startup?
Whether at your stage,
or a different round,
and all of a sudden now
you have sometimes conflicting ideas,
conflicting strategies,
obviously beyond the entrepreneur
directs the path.
But how do you then create this harmony
between the different
institutional investors within a startup?
It's something that sometimes
is hard to do,
and it's sometimes challenging
and often great.
We all have a shared interest,
which is the success of the company.
And we're all there to be
the company's greatest cheerleader.
And ultimately,
we might have different ideas.
But I think our job as investors
is to ask the right questions
and the challenging questions.
And to get the entrepreneur
to think of it outside the box
or even take the opportunity
to reflect, like in board meetings.
You take an opportunity to reflect
three months back
and look three months,
six months, two years forward
and really plan and strategize.
And that's where I think
we can be most helpful.
And I think where
we all have a common thread.
And when you say, "we",
you're meaning yourselves and the other
institutional investors, right?
Yes. Us and any other investors
around the [--].
Very very very cool.
Tal, right before we get
to my favorite question,
what is the one thing
that's the most exciting for you
in this whole journey?
Whether it's  meeting the entrepreneurs
or watching different industries
in different markets, boom.
What is really the most exciting for you
about being an investor?
Because you did have ambitions
to go into other sectors,
but obviously you're having so much fun
what are you doing now.
I feel so grateful to be the enabler
and to help entrepreneurs
fulfill their dreams.
I think it's an incredible opportunity
and it's what wakes me up
and keeps me excited every day.
I love it. I love it.
Okay, and three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Execution driven.
Authentic.
And resilient.
Okay.
Explain a little bit more about these.
Why these three words?
So, I'm extremely execution driven.
I know how to take a lot of ideas
and put them into processes
and execute on them.
And I help build those frameworks
with my entrepreneurs as well.
I think it's part of the great value
that I bring as an investor
Authentic, it's who I am.
It's my core. It's part of me.
And resilience.
Resilience is important part of my job
as I feel as a young woman in tech,
and in an investment world.
It takes a lot of resilience
and a lot of grit,
which I share with the entrepreneurs
I invest in as well.
And it's a big part of how I see
my core values and that I impart.
I love it.
And one thing you would say
to a young entrepreneur
just starting their journey.
Now during the pandemic,
they decide to go and start a startup.
What would you tell them?
Keep at it.
And keep working really hard.
Listen to your customers'
gain market feedback.
And you know better than all the investors
that don't take "No" as a reason
not to fulfill your dream.
I love it.
Tal, thank you very much.
Toda raba.
This was fantastic. Thank you.
Appreciate it. Thank you.
Take care.
Bye bye.